today's question comes from hunter in
alabama
he visits daverams.com to ask i have
thirty seven thousand dollars in student
loans and my fiance has
zero this is our only debt my parents
have volunteered to pay off a large
portion of my student loans over time
but it would be at a much slower rate
than in 12 to 18 months that me and my
then wife would do they regret
not to uh the regret not planning
for me and my siblings to go to college
is it foolish to pay this debt off
quicker as newlyweds than allow
my parents to pay it off over time i
feel bad
bringing debt to the marriage while my
wife
will have zero ha
you know that's a easy question uh some
may say it's not easy but my answer
would be
i will go ahead and get rid of it and
then i would have the conversation with
my parents and say
mom and dad since y'all won't pay back
over time be feel free to pay me back
that
uh but as far as in going into the debt
right now i have no problem with
going ahead and clearing it up with me
and my fiance
and then work out something with your
parents you know
i don't want you sitting around waiting
on your parents because they may come
back and say hey
we actually need three more years or
five more years yeah pay it off in a
year yep
be done with it get it off your plate
and i might even take it off their plate
and just say
add it to my inheritance ah you know
either one
that's not because obviously your mom
and dad don't have any money yeah
and so take the strain off of them take
the strain off of you
be done with it wipe it clean and um
the uh everyone brings something
positive to a marriage and everyone
brings something negative to a marriage
right
so i can promise you in sickness and in
health for richer for poorer
all my worldly goods unto thee i
pledge and this is your marriage vow
and you will have the opportunity many
times
to make chicken soup when she has the
flu
yeah and you'll get the opportunity to
do all
kinds of things the ways that you will
serve your spouse
when they are
you know when they when they have their
down time your downtime is your student
loan
and so no shame no shame in the game
it's where we are she knows it you're
not hiding it from her you're not
springing it on her
she knows you come with this baggage she
also has some baggage
you probably know what it is if you
don't you should go to pre-marriage
counseling and find out about it before
you get married
because everyone comes into a marriage m
per
and imperfect you just you just not and
so
the quicker you figure all that out the
the less arguments you're gonna have you
know what dave i'm glad you said that
too because
a lot of people ask me especially
someone in their their mid
30s they're like yo i can't marry
someone with dad i just refuse to
just to get married with someone who has
forty thousand fifty thousand dollars in
debt
and i just you know i kind of cringe at
that i'm like well hey i mean i get it
you you want to be debt free
i get it i'm single and i want to be
debt free for the rest of my life but if
i if
god introduces me to a great woman um
and she comes to the table with some
debt that's fine
absolutely that is fine absolutely the
ramsey kids were not told to avoid
dating someone with debt they had no
debt
oh but um you know i i'm not going to
say who but some of them came
some of the in-laws came in with some
debt and it was cleaned up immediately
yeah
and uh that's okay that's okay you don't
you don't pick somebody based on that
the god doesn't pick them for you based
on that so would you would you agree
with me dave that it's about the
mindset exactly not what you currently
have
exactly it's not i'm coming into this
marriage with debt and i love that and i
want more of it
that's no that's not we're not going to
do that okay it's more like this
sucks i'm sorry yeah not good with this
and clean it up clean it up just like
that clean and write the check as soon
as you get home from the honeymoon as
soon as we get home get it